former Sex and the City star Cynthia  Nixon is considering a run for governor  of New York  yes and she's challenging incumbent  Andrew Cuomo in the Democratic primary  this is big news and the Cuomo campaign  I guess they're worried about Cynthia  Nixon they've already started digging up  dirt on Cynthia Nixon and earlier today  just hours ago they released this ad  Cynthia Nixon wants to be the next  governor of New York but could you vote  for a candidate who said this if I can  make my bed a place I really want to be  others will feel the same way  ah Field of Dreams exactly if you build  it he will come  and what about this I am gonna turn this  intervention into an inter fun mission  and what about his board  talk about an Abu Dhabi dome  paid for by Andrew Cuomo for governor  [Applause]  you